can we talk about asymptotic freedom
this very idea
that you won the nobel prize for yeah
so it describes a very weird effect
to me uh the the weird in the following
way so the
the the you know the way i think of most
forces or interactions the closer you
are
the stronger the effect the the stronger
the force
yeah right with with quarks
uh the closer they are the the less
so the strong interaction and in fact
they basically act like free particles
when they're
very close that's right yes well but
this requires a huge amount of energy
like can you describe me um
why how does this even work
how weird it is proper description
must bring in uh quantum mechanics and
relativity
and it's uh so a proper description
and equations so a proper description
really is
is probably uh more more more than we
have time for and
uh require quite a bit of patience on
your part but
uh how does relativity come into play
wait wait oh
relativity is important because uh
when when we talk about uh
trying to think about short distances we
have to think about
very large momenta and very large moment
are connected to very large energy
in relativity and so the connection
between
how things behave at short distances and
how things behave at high energy
uh really uh is connected through
relativity
and sort of a slightly backhanded way
quantum mechanics indicates that short
to get to analyze short distances
uh you need to bring in probes
that carry a lot of momentum
this again is related to uncertainty
because
uh it's the fact that you have to bring
in a lot of momentum
that interferes with the possibility of
determining position and momentum at the
same time if you want to determine
position
you have to use instruments that bring
in a lot of momentum
and because of that those same
instruments can't also measure momentum
because they're disturbing the momentum
and then the momentum brings in energy
and yeah so
so that there's also the effect that
asymptotic freedom comes from
uh the possibility of spontaneously
making uh quarks and gluons
for short amounts of time that that
fluctuate into existence and out of
existence
uh and uh the
fact that that can be done with a very
little amount of energy
and and uncertainty and energy
translates into uncertainty in time so
if you do that for a short time you can
do that
uh well it's all it comes in a package
and you can
you can so uh i told you it would take a
while to really
to really explain but the uh
but but the results can be understood i
mean we can state the results
uh pretty simply i think so uh
in everyday life we do encounter some
forces that increase with distance and
kind of
turn off at short distances that's the
way rubber bands work if you think about
it
or you if you pull them hard they
they resist and but but they get flabby
if if
if the rubber band is not not pulled uh
and so there are that can happen
uh in the physical world but what's
what's really difficult is to see how
that could be a fundamental force that's
consistent with everything else we know
and that that's what asymptotic freedom
is it says that uh there are particular
there's a very particular kind of
fundamental force that involves special
particles called gluons with very
special properties
that enables that kind of behavior so
ex there were experiments at the time we
did our work there were experimental
indications
that quarks and gluons
did have this kind of property but there
were no equations that were capable of
capturing it and we found the equations
and showed
how they work and showed how they that
they were basically unique
and this led to a complete theory of how
the strong interaction works which is
the quantum chromodynamics uh we
mentioned earlier
and so uh
so that's the phenomenon that that
quarks
and gluons interact very very weakly
when they're close together that's
connected
through relativity with the fact that
they also interact very very weakly
at high energies so if you have so at
high energies
uh the simplicity of the fundamental
interaction gets revealed
you know at the time we did our work the
clues were very subtle
but nowadays that hot at what are now
high energy accelerators it's all
obvious so
we would have had a much well somebody
would have had a much easier time
20 years later looking at the data you
can sort of see the quarks and gluons
as i mentioned they leave these short
tracks that
would have been much much easier but but
we from fundamental
from indirect clues we were able to
piece together enough to
make that behavior a prediction rather
than a
uh post-diction right so it becomes
obvious at high energies
it becomes very obvious when when we
first did this work
it was uh frontiers of high energy
physics
and at big international conferences
there would always be sessions on
testing qcd and whether these
whether this proposed description of the
strong interaction was in fact correct
and so forth
and it was very exciting they were big
and but
nowadays the same kind of work
but much more precise with
calculations to more accuracy and
experiments that are much
more precise and comparisons that are
very precise
uh now it's called calculating
backgrounds because
it's because people take this for
granted
and one of you and want to see
deviations from the theory which would
be
which would be the the new discoveries
yeah the cutting edge becomes the
foundation of foundation becomes boring
yes uh is is there some
for a basic explanation purposes is
there something to be said about
uh strong interactions in the context of
the
the strong nuclear force for the for the
attraction between
protons yeah well the neutrons versus
the
the interaction between quarks within
protons
well quarks and gluons have the same
relation
basically to nuclear physics as
electrons and photons have to atomic and
molecular physics
so atoms and photons
are the dynamic entities that really
come into play in chemistry and
and atomic physics of course you have to
add the atomic nuclei but those are
small and relatively inert really the
dynamical
part and you know for for most purposes
of chemistry you just say
you have this tiny little nucleus which
this which
qcd gives you don't worry about it it
just
it's there the real the real action is
the electrons moving around
and exchanging and things like that uh
the uh
but okay but we wanted to understand the
nucleus too and
uh so atoms base are
sort of quantum mechanical clouds of
electrons held together by electrical
forces which is photons and then this
radiation which is also
another aspect of photons that's where
all the fun happens is the electrons and
the photons
yeah that's right and the nuclei the
nucleus are kind of the
the uh well they're necessary they give
the positive charge
and most of the mass of matter uh
but they don't since
since they're so heavy they don't move
very much in chemistry
and uh uh i'm oversimplifying
drastically they're not contributing
much of the interaction and
they for most purposes in chemistry you
can just idealize them as concentrations
of positive mass and charge that are
that are uh you don't have to look
inside
but people are curious what's what's
inside what really
and and uh that and that was a big thing
on the agenda of 20th century physics
starting in the
19 well starting with the 20th century
and
unfolding throughout of trying to
understand what
forces held the atomic nucleus together
what it was and so
uh anyway the
the emerge the story that emerges from
qcd
is that very similar to the way
that well broadly similar to the way
that uh
clouds of electrons held together by
electrical forces
uh give you atoms and ultimately
molecules protons
and neutrons are like atoms
made now out of quarks quark clouds held
together by gluons which are
like like like the photons that that
will give the electric forces
but this is giving a different force the
strong force
and uh and the residual forces between
protons and neutrons that uh
are left over from their basic binding
are like the residual forces between
atoms that give molecules but
in the case of protons and neutrons it
gives you atomic nuclei
so again for definitional purposes uh
qcd quantum chromodynamics
is basically the physics of strong
interaction
yeah we understand we now would underst
which i think most physicists would
would say it's the theory of quarks and
gluons and how they interact
but it's a very precise and i think it's
fair to say very beautiful theory
based on mathematical symmetry of a high
order uh and another thing that's
beautiful about it
is that it's kind of
in the same family as electrodynamics
the conceptual structure of this of the
equations
are very similar they're based on having
particles that respond to charge
in a very symmetric way in the case of
electrodynamics it's photons that
respond to electric charge in the case
of
quantum chromodynamics there are three
kinds of charge that we call colors
but they're nothing like colors they
really are like different kinds of
charge
but they rhyme with the same kind of uh
like it's similar kind of dynamics
similar kind of dynamics i call i say
like i like to say that qcd is like
qed on steroids and instead of one
photon you have eight gluons instead of
one
charge you have three color charges but
there's a strong
family resemblance but the context in
which
uh qcd does its thing is it's it's much
higher energies
like that's where it comes well it's a
stronger force
so that to access how its works and kind
of pry things apart you have to
inject more energy and so that that
gives us
in some sense a hint of uh how things
were
in the earlier universe yeah well in
that regard
asymptotic freedom is a tremendous
blessing because it means
things get simpler at high energy and
the universe was born free
born free that's very good yes chris was
born
so so in atomic physics i mean a similar
thing happens in the theory of stars
stars are hot enough that uh the
interactions between electrons and
photons are
they're they're liberated they don't
form atoms anymore they make a plasma
which in some ways is simpler to
understand
you don't have complicated chemistry and
in the early universe according to qcd
similarly atomic nuclei dissolved and
took the constituent
quarks and gluons which are moving
around very fast and
interacting in relatively simple ways
and so this uh
this opened up the early universe to
scientific
calculation
you